Thank you so much for being here, guys, it's an absolute pleasure, yeah, the owner's room
today, what's going on in here is totally different than what's going on next door,
next door is recorded, so if you want to pick up some of the product info and everything
else, you can, the breaks are synchronized, right, so you'll be able to see your team
members next door and uh we've got babysitters there to make sure that they're not throwing
things so that they're playing nicely with their friends um we did this last year in vancouver and
what we found is the value that came out of this room was just resounding because people
were like oh my god you need to do this again um the uh yeah the information that comes out
I'm here today, guys, really is about bettering your business, but feel free to ask questions,
collaborate, make friends, sit around the table.
Some of you guys may be competing with each other.
Some of you guys may be from totally opposite ends of the country.
We really are a community of salon owners.
We've realized over the years that this industry is much stronger when we are together.
So make friends.
Mingle, especially, you know, everybody in this room is facing the same struggles and
those big challenges as entrepreneurs as you guys are.
We do have a couple housekeeping things.
That's the schedule.
We have door prizes.
So there are ballots that you and your team are doing.
You have to go around to the trade show floor
in order to get the ballots.
Once they're all completed, they go into a big drum.
We pull winners out of that.
The red drink tickets, there should
be one drink ticket per person.
If your team member is under 19, please don't give them a drink ticket, and then have another, right?
Don't have to give your staff members any drinks. Keep them on your phone.
The blue ticket you guys have is for the raffle.
Elaine's got a box, so please put your blue tickets at some point in that box.
We're going to be drawing winners after every session.
This is for the Brainstorm 4 guys.
You're going to go around all of the vendors on the pre-show floor.
They've got bingo dabbers. They are going to dab their specific box.
When you are done, there is a drum. You're going to put that in the drum.
Yourself and your staff are going to be doing this.
You guys are the only ones with the blue ticket.
You're going to keep one side and put the other side in here.
You put both in, and oh well.
The prize will be a walking treadmill from the ballot box, which is super cool.
We don't have it here, but we will ship it directly to you.
That's from the Big Drone.
All right?
So, let's go around the Facebook floor.
These are super hot and super cool.
Hot girl watch and all that.
There's also, in your booklets, a worksheet.
Now, this is for yourselves personally.
You know, part of what we're trying to encourage you guys to do is aid better your business,
and part of that comes from bettering yourself.
So I encourage you, go through and take a look at this worksheet, set some goals for yourself,
set some positive intentions, feel free to take this act up in about three months,
you know, if you want to review and see how well you're doing.
I say give yourself a more faithful praise than you probably could have given yourself,
but this is just kind of a really nice way to do that.
So our first guest we have here today, guys, I was actually in Nashville,
There's a National Expo there and I had the fortune of walking into a room and listening to this guy speak.
I thought I'd been in this industry for 40 years and I thought I knew everything.
I'm sitting here listening to Mike and I'm like, oh my God, this guy is blowing my mind.
I come back to the office, I come into Elaine's office and I'm like, how do you know my floor?
And we've got to get into the Expo and she's like, yeah, yeah, yeah, Expo, we'll look at it.
Elaine, a couple weeks later, goes down to Columbus, falls in love with Mike Moore, falls
in the same room.
She comes back and says, oh my God, we got to hire Mike Moore.
I was like, Elaine, that's a fantastic idea.
I've learned after 14, 15 years of marriage, sometimes you get better at being right than
being right.
So Mike is from sunny California.
He truly, truly does understand the wellness industry and where it's heading and certainly
how to win at it.
The wellness space is shifting fast.
We're going to talk a little bit about that in just a second.
And so long as the studios that will thrive in 2026 are the ones making smarter,
data-backed decisions right now.
This is why exactly Mike is here today.
We both speak twice. We look through your agenda.
The first session, Mike and I, Mike's going to go through.
There'll be more wellness, kind of industry-focused.
The second session, I'm really strongly encouraged,
they're more numbers-focused.
I'm really, really getting down to the data.
So with over 30 years of building experience,
30 years of experience building, scaling, and transforming wellness businesses,
Mike doesn't just speak his theory, he also speaks from real world results.
He's a song owner as well, guys.
From pioneering more accessible wellness models to helping operators grow profitably without sacrificing their friends,
his insights and practical proven knowledge are immediately actionable.
You will learn things today that you will take home and implement tomorrow.
At least I certainly hope so.
So, today's expo is all about bold ideas and bright, exciting product launches and serious inspiration,
and Mike is here to deliver that.
So, please, everybody, give him a warm welcome for Mike.
Okay, I hope everybody can hear me right now.
Can everybody hear me?
My wife tells me I speak too loudly.
Okay. So, you want me to
Okay, that's good.
So, first of all, thank you to Nick and Elaine
for inviting me to be here it's really flattering because at the end of the day I do what you do
every single day I show up to work I work with a great team of people who make me look a lot better
than I am but I'm in this long salon business I started in 93 with a single canning salon I
exited out of the advertising business I started a company when I was 25 hired a receptionist that
made us sound really big and in 97 we sold that company with representatives
in 218 cities across the nation and so we know a little bit about advertising
a little bit about promotion that's what we specialize in we did all the
block stock print media for Harbor Petroleum the International Guard
California Highway Patrol every single University across the nation was our
plan and when we started having kids my wife said you need to pick between being
being on the plane every day for your two daughters.
And so after I made the wrong decision
and woke up in the hospital, I made the right decision
and exited into the tanning business.
So having said that, I was reading and thinking,
probably wondering why I'm looking at the card.
And they said, you know, if you're this first speaker,
you gotta warm the audience up.
And I'm not a professional speaker.
I'm behind a desk most of my day.
And so I thought, well, okay,
okay, you've got to get people engaged.
So if I were to give this debit card to a lady in the lane,
shuffle them, do whatever you want,
place them on the stage right here, face down,
and I'll come back in and I'll tell you,
you guys can pick any card you want,
and I'll tell you whether it's red or black.
With that impression, you're laughing at me already
because that's not very impressive, I know.
But if I did it like two or three times,
with that impression, probably.
But if I took the deck of cards, left the room, had a lane, shuffled them, placed them face down, and I came back in the room, and I told you, pick any card you want on the stage, and I'll tell you whether it's a seven of diamonds, eight of clubs, queen of hearts, I'll tell you the specific card it is with that impression.
And if I did it three or four times, that would really impress you, right?
So that's not what you're going to get today.
toward the picking the red or black that's that's tiny for we're at so i just want to set
right so the expectation we got kind of lowered a little bit didn't build it up too much
so thank you for being here and um i think somewhere they should be quicker
oh my god i know it exists here
so we told you a little bit about us we began in 1993
okay so today we're going to focus on the wellness in just a little bit we're going
to focus on our for a couple of hours we'll focus more on the numbers and the data and the
analytics um i'm i'm an analytical person by nature so making moves in this industry and you
guys in canada know more than anything i mean equipment is not inexpensive building a salon
is not inexpensive and so when i first got into the industry back in 1993 we built out a 1200
square foot store i think we furnished it with uh equipment and i think we were all in at 250 000
Now you can spend $100,000 for one piece of equipment, yeah?
So it's changed dramatically.
So now making a profitable business, doing what we do has become even more important.
So we look at companies over the years that have evolved.
How many of us remember Blockbuster?
Right?
Right.
And Blockbuster lived in the moment.
They didn't live in the future.
In fact, there was a quote by the CEO of Blockbuster who said,
neither Redbox nor Netflix is even on the radar.
We don't even consider them competitors.
You think that was a mistake?
Yeah, big mistake.
Who's around today, Blockbuster, Netflix, or Redbox?
Blockbuster isn't, right?
Yahoo missed an opportunity to buy Google for a billion dollars.
Now, that sounds ridiculously expensive
until you figure that Google's probably worth trillions.
Another big mistake.
They lived in the moment.
They didn't live in the future.
What we're talking about today isn't mistakes that other people have made.
We're talking about mistakes that we could possibly make.
Nick and Elaine and their team have provided an incredible opportunity.
And I've had an immeasurable privilege of speaking to my peers.
You guys do the same thing I do.
My value is not any different than yours.
But interestingly enough, over several years, I'll hear people now say,
oh my man i heard about the membership thing i'm going to do that when i leave today we're going to
do that and then the next year i'll see them and you know what they say oh gosh i gotta do it i
gotta do it i just my customers will kill me if i do something like that and then the next year
they're like things are tough i gotta make change and the next year i don't see them anymore you
know why they're not in business you have an opportunity here today they've presented you with
to learn, to discuss, to have dialogues about purchasing new equipment
and the direction that you're going to go.
Take advantage of it.
You know, people ask me, what's the one big thing you would suggest?
I don't know that there's one big thing.
I think there's lots of little things.
But I will tell you, I'm a research analyst.
I'm a gracious reader.
If there's something that piques my attention, I will pursue it at the end of the year.
And today, when people say, well, what's the one big thing that makes a difference?
I think that was it.
I wasn't satisfied with just saying, okay, we're doing all right.
The beds we've had still operate.
I mean, people still get splinters, but they'll be okay.
Right?
It's time to change the equipment.
So part of what I focus on is facts and data.
Because facts and data, you know, how many of us have employees?
And this is really unusual for me, by the way.
Usually I'm speaking to an audience that is a lot of employees, probably maybe most employees,
and it's really easy to impress them.
You tell them, oh, I have a store, I've been in business for five years.
They're like, wow, right?
Owners, not so much.
You guys just have to take a little bit more.
So how many of us know the data behind our stores?
You cannot move forward.
You're like a ship.
We are like a ship without a compass.
How do we go in that direction if we don't know where we've been?
we could be going in circles.
Do you ever feel like it's just hard to figure out back in the day
when some of us first got started,
we gauged everything by sessions, did we not?
Sessions were going up, sessions going down.
But then along came sunless and people who tanned
three or four times a week now only came once every ten days
and screwed up our sessions.
We didn't know how to look at things anymore.
We're going to look at all of those numbers and analytics.
So did you know how much do you think the average someone
salon makes now, and we're going to add about 30% to this of Canada, but how much do you
think the average salon across Canada generates in an average year? Anybody?
400,000?
400,000, a little bit lower than that. The average salon in the U.S. generates about
225,000, and looking at the analytics for Canada, about 350. Now, to put this in perspective,
perspective, all of my data, I do the analytics for roughly, right now, about 318 stores.
We have 20.
We had 28.
We've combined some of our stores.
I consult for Suntan City, 250 stores.
I consult for Palm Beach and 800 stores.
They're all trying to get into wellness.
And I'm very analytically driven.
I look at equipment.
I look at the numbers generated off of it.
And currently, we do the data and consulting for lots of stores, stores that have 25, 30, 50 store chains.
So a lot of the data that I'm giving you is compiled. It's not just our numbers.
And by the way, people say, well Mike's from California, so every store they have are in these big metro areas.
Not true. We have a store in Reno, Nevada. We have a store in Chico. We have a store in Yuma City, which is a farming community.
So when you look at our website, when you start isolating some of those locations, you're going to find they're in small communities.
And that allows me to really dive deep into how we do things.
The average number of customers within this store, 1,000 to 1,500.
How many of you have ever heard somebody advertise in a store and they say they have a database of 10,000 people, right?
There's one for sale that we were just looking at.
and they have a database of 10,000 people,
yet their community is 2,500.
I want to know how that happens, right?
They're for sale for like $15,000.
And some of their equipment is actually made out of plastics
and metal now.
They've actually transitioned from wood.
Now, here's an interesting fact for you.
You might want to write this down.
This is a really easy mathematical one
that we're going to use later this afternoon.
In any given community, it doesn't matter where you're at, any given community, and I consult for European salons, I consult for, I mean, we get people in from all over the world.
We have a 28,000 square foot office, we have a 4,000 square foot spa and showroom next door, and so we get people coming in from all over the world.
Here's an interesting fact.
If you take any community, roughly 10% of that community is your customer.
Those are people that would be a tanning customer.
So if you look at a community with, let's pick 30,000 people,
roughly 3,000 people is what you're after.
Of the 3,000 people, roughly 2.5% to 4% will be subscription customers.
Those would be people signing up on memberships, 2.5% to 4%.
We're going to pick the high side, so we're going to say 4%.
So that kind of gives us a foundation for what we're looking at.
Elaine and her team were kind enough to print some worksheets out for us,
so later on we're going to be giving those to you so that you have those
for when we're going through the analytics.
Oh, they're in there? Okay.
That's how good Elaine is. They're already there.
The annual customer spend is $150 to $175.
Now, here's where a lot of people get lost.
And they'll say, well, my customers spend $500 to $700.
Anybody feel that way?
$500 to $700.
We have customers spend $1,000.
Yep, I hear you.
But if all of your customers spend $1,000 and you have 1,000 customers in your database,
then your store is doing $1 million, right?
And they say, well, no.
No, no, our store is 400,000.
Well, you either don't have 1,000 customers,
or your customers aren't spending what you think they are.
Does that make sense, right?
So you have to have the data,
because we're all consumers in this room.
We might be business owners,
but at the end of the day,
when you talk to people and you say,
you know what, if you have a favorite place that you shop,
and you go there and they no longer carry what you like,
what do you do?
You go to a different location, right?
You pick a different store.
Because as consumers, we tell business people what we think of their business practices with our wallet.
The same thing your customers do.
The same thing our customers do.
When they don't like our decision-making, what do they do?
They go elsewhere.
They go to a competitor.
They go home, and in the mail they see something that says 50 cents off less than what you're being charged, and so they go.
So part of what we're getting in this industry, we do not agree, is we're recycling customers.
It's not like 10,000 new people move into a community and we have a whole new selection of customers.
Some of these we recycle.
So those are really important metrics.
We're going to talk about those later this afternoon.
How many people know the average number of times a customer comes in your spa?
Anybody want to guess?
For the whole year.
This is for the whole year.
So if you were to average all your customers and say our customers come in this many times
a year, what would the average be?
Average 16 times a year.
About one and a half times a year.
And I know some of your faces right now tell the story.
They're like, are you kidding me?
I have done this for hundreds and hundreds of stores.
I have yet, never yet in 30 years, seen somebody over 22 sessions a year.
Now you say, well, I have customers that come in every day.
You're right. You do. But you also have customers who came in one time. So here's my first best piece of advice for you from this meeting. Never build a platform of business around what 3% do.
so often I consult with people and they'll say yeah but but if I price it like that all my
customers are going to come in every day they're going to abuse me no your customers come in one
and a half times a month empty rooms make us no money volume solves a myriad of problems
and I'm going to say something probably I gotta look and see if the equipment guys are in here
because they're going to hate me for what I'm about to say but it's true but it's not true
and you'll understand when I get to the end.
Poor Randy's already going, oh my gosh, what's he going to say?
When I look at my equipment, and we have a plethora of modalities,
I don't care whether the tanning bed works or it doesn't work.
I don't care whether the sun sprays right or it doesn't spray.
I don't care whether the panther machine works.
I don't care whether the massage works.
You know what I care about as a business owner?
Will you pay me to use it again?
That's what I care about.
will you pay me to use it again?
If you're not going to
it doesn't matter, right?
So
when I look at
what works and what doesn't
I look at the success
of whether somebody's going to pay me to use it again.
So as a business owner, I follow
the model. How many of you have heard of Nordstrom?
Right? How many of you shop at Nordstrom?
Good.
Alright.
John Nordstrom, I listened to a seminar by John one time, and he said something very
profound, and I loved it, and I've used it ever since.
So part of what I'm using on stage today is I pick the meetings from everybody, and
now I get the credit.
John Nordstrom once was asked by an interviewer, they had gone to J.C. Penney's, and they
bought something, and they were talking about the success of Nordstrom and their return
policy and they took an item from JC Penney's with the tag on it and this was on the news
and I think some of you are shaking your head because you probably saw the same thing
and they took it to Nordstrom and Nordstrom gave them full credit on a JC Penney's tag.
Crazy, right? It wasn't even from them and so when they asked John Nordstrom, John why
are you so liberal with your return policy? And he said this, he said in any given market
It doesn't matter what it is.
In any given market, roughly 3% of consumers abuse a policy.
Why would we punish 97% of our customers for what 3% do?
Do you get it now? Right?
Sometimes we build memberships and packages around 3%.
We're so afraid that they're going to abuse the process
that we start saying unlimited tanning.
you can tan up to eight sessions a month.
Unlimited sunless, up to four times a month.
We start attaching all of these streams.
We know people are only coming 16 times a year.
It's really easy math.
On that sheet that Elaine provided for you,
if you put in the number of sessions
and the number of unique customers,
divide the unique customers into the sessions,
we even put the formula there for you,
you're going to get the average number of sessions.
That's what you're seeing on a yearly basis.
That's how often they're coming in.
So when we're building processes,
build them around what the amount of people,
the larger amount of people will use,
without accurate knowledge about our brand's performance,
and we're really, really gonna,
we're just gonna beat this thing to death this afternoon.
When we know the analytics,
and we can see changes that we're making we have profound changes 2015 there was
this ripple on the water I always like to say it's like I I don't know that I'm
the best operator but I'm good at looking further into the distance I like
working five years out and in the advertising business they you really
learn that process and so I kept hearing this 2014-2015 greatest thing about
wellness and there weren't really any wellness places. It was just wellness was starting
to pop up on Google Analytics. And I thought, okay, I'm going to pivot to wellness. Now
why? Well, if you have the knowledge that all the money you're spending to get new customers,
you're spending for 10% of a market, 4% of a subscription customer. You know what percentage
I'm getting on the wellness side? 100%. We have people come into our spa and they say,
man, I've never seen so many diversity of black, white, Asian, Hispanic,
you have young, you have old.
Why?
Because wellness applies to everybody.
And so now, you know, we see numbers that are just insane.
The spas do numbers that are insane.
And probably the biggest compliment, I was doing some consulting for a large chain,
and we were helping him get into the wellness side,
what to do first the analytics of what to do and how to do it and he called me two weeks after
opening a 4 000 square foot store and i swear this is his words verbatim mike everything you
said is true 80 of our customers are using wellness we've had more memberships in the past
two weeks than any store we've ever opened why i'm not that smart because he's attracting 100
hundred percent of the community no longer are we going after this white
Caucasian female that fits in a certain demographic we have Gen Z's that are
growing up without even knowing who we are so that's what we're talking about
the reason I'm here is to help us all become more successful sometimes the
hardest thing to do is be the pioneer in doing something right because it's
expensive mistakes are expensive and that's what I'm here to help you with
and understand. So part of what we wanted to get away from back in 2015, like you, I spend a lot
of time, a lot of time with my, primarily my district team and my executive team, and we just
watch cameras. And there's a saying that goes like this, complexity is the enemy of execution.
Have you ever thought of something for your brand and you're like, oh man, okay, here's how we'll do
we'll sell this but if they do this they get this and then if they buy so many of
these they get this and then if they want on a one-time offer we'll do it
this way you ever done that I see something that's right and then you
watch your team and four and a half hours later the girls I'm explaining it
to the customer it's too complex it's never gonna work simplicity is your best
friend so currently are you offering this does your dialogue go something
something like this. Welcome to California Sun. Thanks for coming in. At California Sun,
you know, we're glad you're here. We offer tanning, tanning, tanning, and tanning. And
then, if you're interested, we also have tanning products, tanning lotion, and tanning
extenders. Which one of those would you like? Or maybe a customer decides they just don't
want to tan any longer. Now, they're not saying they don't like your brand. They're not saying
they don't love your team. They're just saying they need you right now. They need a break.
and you say but wait wait wait wait don't go anywhere I'm counting on you to
make my living we offer tanning tanning or tanning as an alternative you see the
problem in essence we are the creators in this room of our own seasonality we limited
ourselves to a very specific tight vertical market and we've given no room
for growth and that's why I'm here the wellness market finally gives us an
opportunity now do not misunderstand what i'm saying because i've had people come up and say
well you you're giving out the tanning not at all tanning is wellness light therapy is wellness
i'm going to show you a quote from the wellness institute which references light therapy how many
of you in this room would agree with me that mental illness is a real thing if your hand
doesn't go up i have a son who suffers from mental illness right severe severe anxiety
diabetes and depression. I get it. I get it in ways I never thought I would. What did
his doctor prescribe? Sunlight. Sunlight. You cannot tell me that sunlight doesn't make
you feel better, doesn't make you healthier, doesn't create vitamin D. Vitamin D throttles
your immune system, right? Sunlight is wellness. They can live harmoniously. And if they can
live harmoniously then why aren't we doing it why haven't we added alternatives to our light therapy
that give our customers other options to stay with us now we talked earlier about the thousand
fifteen hundred customers remember that number let's say on average that you charged a hundred
dollars let's say a customer is worth a hundred dollars a month and you added just one month to
To those 1,000 people, this is easy math, $100 times 1,000 people is $100,000.
You just made extra for free.
You didn't add any more customers.
You didn't spend any more money to get customers.
You didn't add any more labor.
You didn't add any more equipment.
You made $100,000 for free by adding one extra month to the length of how long they stayed with you.
Now, since we're talking money, who here, I'm trying to watch my clock because I've got limited time, so I'm going to go fast.
Since we're talking money, who here at the end of my presentation wants the easiest way to make $30,000 to $90,000 without adding one extra person, one extra hour to your labor, one extra piece of equipment?
You don't have to do anything. I'll give you the key to add $30,000 to $90,000 in the next six months. Anybody in?
No.
I'll buy you equipment later.
This is the easiest thing, and everybody I've given it to, so at the last show in Columbus, I was in Nashville,
And so then I was in Columbus, I had people coming up saying, oh my God, this was the
easiest thing I ever did.
On average, our company makes about $800,000 a year from this idea and it doesn't cost
us one cent and we didn't have to buy one piece of a book.
Okay.
You ready?
Stay till the end.
All right.
I'll give it to you.
I promise I'll give it to you.
All right.
can you guys hear me okay oh yeah so to give you guys an idea the red is candy now I'm not in any
way shape or form suggesting tanning is doing bad it's just right it's plateaued we're climbing at
about two to four percent a year that's the tanning industry we have how many of us would
agree that there's a pretty good amount of attrition in the tanning right so stores changing
hands people going out people coming in but the wellness is exploding and here's some interesting
interesting numbers the wellness industry in 2024 5.9 billion and 20 by 2023 we're going to see it
reach almost 10 billion dollars in growth there's a phrase that I heard one time in the advertising
world when I was was really young and it stayed with me the whole time there is far more money
money to be made in creating a way than in writing. Think about that. How many of us
heard about this thing called mystic tan? Back in the 90s, right? Everybody hear about
some of this tan? And then some people said, well, I'm never going to do fake tan. I'm
not going to expose my customers to that. So they didn't get on board. And two, three,
four years go by and they watch their customer base start declining. And then eventually
what did they buy? They bought a mystic pen, right? Because it was an alternative that
represented a new modality that kept your customer. Sometimes it's not about how much
it costs us, it's about how much it costs us. Make sense? So, same thing with wellness.
So, I want to pause here for a second. I'm going to give you this story that resonates
resonates so deeply with me because it's how we operate as an entire brand. Anybody come
from farming? Anybody? Farming? You can admit it. It's okay. All right. So farming. So you
guys will get this. So there's a farmer's wife. They had a pretty good-sized farm. They
finally got to the point where they said, we're getting a little bit too large, and
we need a farm here. And so they ran an app, but just nobody applied. Finally, this young
young man came and they said, well, what experience do you have? And he said, well, I don't really
have experience on a farm, but I sleep well at night. The farmer's like, that's awesome,
but I need help on a farm. So he and his wife interviewed this young man. They really took
a liking to him and finally his wife said, look, honey, nobody else has applied. Why
don't we at least give him a shot? So he's there for a couple of weeks. As luck would
have it, they get a warning that there's a massive storm coming in with wind gusts
like nothing they've ever seen. Kind of sounds familiar lately, right? Snow they've never
seen. And so they hear the wind howling at night. The farmer wakes up his wife. They
start getting dressed. The farmer goes downstairs. Where do you think they find the farmhand?
Sleeping. Sleeping. Sleeping. And so they rush out to the barn. And the farmer wants
to put all the tools away so they don't get caught up in the rain or the wind and hurt
hurt somebody. And so when he goes to put all the rakes and the shovels away, why he
finds they're all latched down. They've all been put away. They're all safe and secure.
So then he turns his attention to the farm animals, the most important thing. They've
been well fed. They've been put under blankets. They're in the barn. They're secure. They're
calm. They're safe. He turns his attention to the hay. Well, the hay has tarp looms
thrown over them. The tarpaulins are snapped
down. They're secured. It's not
going anywhere. In fact, he looks up
and the shutters have all been closed and latched.
And it's at that
point it hits him.
When the young man said
he sleeps well at night,
it's because of what he did during the day.
See, the greatest predicator
for how we will do during a storm
is what we do during the
fall. So if you want to know
how do we do when things get tough,
look at how you're doing
and what you're doing when things are calm.
If we're not investing in new equipment,
if we're not thinking about new strategies,
if we're not looking at our numbers when it's calm,
we're gonna get destroyed when there's a storm.
I remember back in 2008, I watched quite a few
of my friends get annihilated through the recession.
Why?
They were overcapitalized.
They didn't have enough leverage to withstand it.
They weren't doing any planning.
You know what they were doing during the calm times,
during the good times?
taking vacations, they were living at large, buying new cars, and they were relying on
next month's income to pay for all of this. No planning. If you could do anything today,
I require my team, when I take my team, they are required to have five takeaways, five
articulable takeaways from every convention we go to. In February, we'll be at this show
called the magic show it's a merchant garment apparel show we move about 1.8 million a year
just in apparel in our lobbies i'm not suggesting getting into that there's a lesson to be learned
there but we've become pretty good at it so we go to these shows from those shows they will have to
come away with five takeaways that we can improve on or better ourselves you have a whole show here
you have your employees next door listening on how to improve your brand, is this just
a fun getaway? This is an opportunity to start conversations with people about how we can
improve our brand. I want new equipment. I'm not sure I can afford new equipment. Have
that conversation. I want new equipment. I'm not sure what equipment. Have the conversation.
What we do in the calm determines how we'll do in the storm.
Now maybe the storm isn't a recession.
Maybe it's not economic.
Maybe it's a good competitor moving right across the street.
I started with 46 competitors, 19 of which were champions.
46 competitors, 19 were champions.
Today I do not have one competitor in all of greater Sacramento, Northern California, and Nevada.
that. I am an animal when it comes to getting market share. I don't care what it takes,
I will get their market. It is far easier to steal a customer than earn one. So if you're
losing customers, then maybe we ought to think about our own rent. I'm not better than them.
I think if we were to raise our hands and say, okay, let's everybody take our averages,
at the end of that conversation there's only going to be one number one person
in this room would you not agree at the end of the day somebody's going to be
number one and all of us all underneath that but that doesn't mean we're less
there we might have different strengths maybe some of us are really good at
planning maybe some of us are great at sales maybe some of us are great at
training take the opportunity here friends to have discussions like you
never have. You have an opportunity with Ubalox team, with all the vendors here. I want new
equipment. What can I do to get it? I want to move in this direction. What advice would
you give? Remember, you know, collectively we get the input from our own team and maybe
a couple of friends that we have in the industry. They're getting the input of hundreds if not
thousands of people. Why wouldn't we capitalize on that? And yet time and time again I go
to a show and and the first thing that people will say when they call me is i saw you at the
show this and the other i'd love you to do this can you help me okay did you talk to anybody
at the show no i really didn't have time what'd you do that's what these shows are for they put
them on for you this is the first time i've ever been to a people like show but i'm telling you
the amount of energy and time and passion in talking to nick and elaine and their team
my goodness like it's nuts and this is for you and I'll be honest I didn't come here for free
so they invested in you take the time to invest in yourself pay them back that favor
because more times than not when I do consulting it's amazing how many times people have been to
trade shows and never asked a vendor a simple question it's it's absolutely bonkers doesn't
make any sense. So take that opportunity. So we're going to dive deep. This kind of
gives you an idea. We track everything within our brain. We have data servers. We host our
own data. We have servers that do nothing but compile data every single minute of every
single day. And then they re-spin it. Anybody ever hear of Helios? Right? So in 1995, I
I got in business in 1993, my brain, I can't stand steel,
so I didn't like the software out there.
So I started a software company, I had our ad firm still.
In 2000, ETS, which is now New Sunshine, came along
and they bought Solon Explorer from us.
And we had just over a thousand customers at the time
we did tanning software, they merged it with Helios,
which then became Helios Explorer.
Now, having said that, today I do some of them,
But, all said and done, I'm big on data, I'm big on analytics, and you can see this is from a store. Now, I'm going to give you, only because I know you want it, I'm going to give you the secret that I told you I was going to give you earlier. Are you ready? Okay.
Okay. And in our numbers here, and these are actual numbers, this is what we pay our managers off of, so it does not include some things, and I'm going to get this to you. Our numbers do not include chargebacks. They don't include tax, of course, so we remove that from the number. It doesn't include shrink.
So if you had shrinkage in the store, we deduct that from your number at full retail.
80% of all theft in your store will take place by an employee. That's a fact.
You can Google it right now.
8 out of 10 dollars that disappear from your store will take place from employees.
So we deduct any shrink at full retail.
Now it's interesting, when we switched to this system and we started deducting at full retail, guess what?
our customers stop stealing we'll figure it out right so our street changed quite a bit back here
so we also don't include and here it comes we do not include our facility every membership is
charged an annual 30 facility fee and it's on their first draft following their first month
so let's put it in respect if you came in on the 14th of the month 16th 9th whatever day that is
your membership would go to the ninth of the following month on the first of the
following month we would prorate your fee whatever days are remaining in that
one plus a $30 facility fee so if you cancel or leave when you come back guess
what you have to pay $30 facility fee it'll start all over again if you have a
thousand customers that's $30,000 you will pay the facility fees now because of the churn rate right
The recycle rate in customers, some of our people that we consult for see $30,000, $60,000, $90,000.
Last year, we made a little over $800,000 in facility fees.
And you ready?
Not one complaint.
Nobody.
Anybody belong to a gym?
Right?
What do they charge?
Go ahead and say it.
Facility fees.
Right?
They charge an annual fee.
Nobody can buy it.
Gary Strong from Sunless. He does it in his stores. We just instituted across a 25-store chain in the Midwest.
And they said, we've got people ready. We just know that shit's going to hit the fan. Pardon the phrase, right?
We know what's going to happen. Nothing.
She said they got a few calls from when they told people it was their facility fee, just like on their membership form.
They said, okay, I just wasn't sure what it was for.
The easiest thing you can do is add a facility fee.
And sometimes people say, well, what does it go to?
Well, you know those five new elements we just added?
You know the red light waves we just added?
You know the cocoon pods that we just added?
That's your facility fees at work.
Now do they feel better about that facility fee?
See, nobody wants to pay something for nothing.
When they see it at work, they're glad to do it.
And I've done facility fees now for 10 years.
I've encouraged multitudes of people not one of them not one and I swear on my
life not one has ever come back to me and said that was a bad decision every
single one of them has said I think you should raise it not one some people have
started out with $10 they thought $30 was too aggressive some people started out with $20
some people started every single one of them every single one and I'll give you
references but because of every single one is now 30 a month it's the easiest way so that is
not included in these numbers so this store in 2024 did 1.16 this is a 2800 square foot store
we have i think 11 12 different modalities in this store this store we'll look at its session
count a little bit later today so you can kind of compare to your session count and see how that
works we also track our average so we know from a planning perspective how do
you plan your year if you don't know what your average month looks like your
average your overall revenue per session which is the first highlight and your
distinct customer annual average and here's the reason why I brought this
slide if you look up our distinct customer annual revenue was $108 at this
the store. And it sits now, this does not include facility fees, chargebacks, anything else, it now sits at $319.
This is a store that generates over a million dollars a year. What did we change? We didn't add on to the store.
We didn't add more people, we didn't, you know, we recycle employees just like you. And what changed? Anybody know?
No? Well, one more change. Look at the pivot. We had 4,400 distinct customers five years ago. We're sitting at 3,185 doing $600,000 more. Why? Because if we can get those customers that we already have to buy an extra month or an extra two months, think about what that means.
So 1,000 people, 1,500 people at this particular store, distinct customers, they have 3,185 distinct or unique customers.
Does everybody understand what that means?
So if there's two of us, we might tan 10 times each. That's 20 sessions.
But there's only two people who make up the 20 sessions.
Those are your distinct customers.
So if we look at the Disney customers, we have a thousand less than we had five years ago doing $600,000 a year more.
How's that possible?
Because we took those customers, and if they each bought an extra two months at $100 a month, that's $600,000.
Well, how did we get them to buy two extra months?
We gave them reasons to stay.
When people say they don't want to tan anymore, are they telling you they don't like you?
No.
Are they saying they don't want to come to your store anymore?
Maybe they just want a break.
And now, instead, we say, well, were you aware that especially going into fall,
we have modalities that will keep you healthy.
You can also use light services and light therapy as much as you want.
But to complement that, we have the cocoon infrared.
We have the angel sun.
We have cold plants.
We have red light.
We have infrared.
read. We have people that come in, we spend an amazing amount of time watching our employees
and how they execute things across the counter. We learn a lot just watching and listening
to them. Did we make packages? Did we make the presentations too difficult? And then
we go back and we adjust to make it simpler. If you can't close a sale, here's an interesting
statistic for you, that up to four minutes, you have an 80% chance of closing the sale.
Up to four minutes, 80% chance. How many of you know that a customer's decision making,
from the moment they walk over the threshold, what's the time frame they count? They're
going to make an impression of your store within how long? 18 seconds. 18 seconds. You've
it starts with us. It starts with what we do, how we do it. In our employee manual,
dress and grooming is a part of your uniform. If your hair and makeup is not done, you will
be sent home. When that customer comes in, maybe you guys do it different here in Canada.
See, in the U.S., when our customers come in, we show them the packages we have and
then we tell them how much it's going to be. Now in Canada, you might do it different.
In Canada, you say, go use the services. When you're done using them, come up front
will negotiate a price no I don't think we know that right so then what do they
find if they don't get to use it first not like a car you don't get to test
drive it and then come back and say man that's amazing I can't believe it's so
much different than the 1984 Pinto right this is amazing they're buying you
they're buying the person behind the counter that's who they're buying if that
person doesn't love the car maybe they came in and they didn't have time you
ever heard this one before i didn't have time to do my clothes i didn't have time to do laundry
i know you look like it
i just woke up and i but i came in i know you look like it
all of our employees you go to our website they're all in fabletics black scrubs
if you were to ask our employees and we do we have so many people come in and they ask
would you ever go back oh we love our scrubs they love them love it they wouldn't go back at all
Now, Fabletics for the girls, they get it. They understand Fabletics is not like those baggy little scrubs they wear at the hospital.
They're cute, they're fun, but how many of us have had this experience?
How many of us have had an employee, or maybe we were there ourselves before we got into the business,
and we went and interviewed, and then she goes home and her mom and dad says,
says, hey, how job search do you go today?
It went, I got a job
at a tanning salon.
And mom and dad say, honey, come on,
you can do better.
We know that happens, true?
Right? I see you guys nodding your heads.
It happens to me.
But now, think of the pivot.
She goes home. How job search go today?
I got a job at the wellness spa.
Mom, I get my scrubs next week.
I'm so excited. I didn't realize
they do, oh my goodness, cryotherapy,
cold plunge, wellness, hey, go.
They do infrared, red light, light therapy, galore.
It's amazing.
I'm so proud of you.
See, the biggest battle your employees face is often at home.
And all of your heads are nodding right now.
You get it.
The biggest battle they face.
How many of you have somebody in your life, when you first started in this business,
they're like, come on, how can you be that tired?
You just work at a tanning salon.
You're like, oh, I'm going to kill you.
i might slice your head off right now right i put 44 000 steps on these feet today
on concrete i bent over and cleaned more beds and you'll clean in a lifetime in one day
you guys get it now imagine that's what they go on right so can we change the environment behind
the counter these are the people that make our choices for us oftentimes if they're in a bad
out of boot and they come into work, how do you think your day's going to go?
And so we really focus on starting with our team.
What does it look like?
How do they dress?
Imagine this.
If you're a woman, you're going to go to a special event, and I really want to drive
you home because it's the biggest weakness I see in our industry.
You're going to go to an event, or maybe you reminisce and you go back to when you were
in high school, and you're going to go to prom.
And for some of us, that might be a little bit of a stretch.
We might have to go a few more laps.
So we'll just say you're going to go to a special event.
And so you go to a Nordstrom makeup counter.
You're going to have your makeup done.
And the gal is putting some stuff in the corner.
And as she turns around, she's got these two big red circles on her cheek.
It looks like somebody that does clown makeup did her lipstick, right, all over her face.
She's got evil eyebrows going on, right?
Her hair is all frizzy.
And she says, here, I'm going to make you look beautiful.
like I'm out of here. I'm going someplace else. Do we know that she couldn't? No. But
our theater of the mind, right? In the first 18 seconds, we decided that what we see is
going to be what we get. When you walk into your store, is what you see what you get?
Sometimes I've had people say, well, no, I mean, our store is old, but I mean, we have
have the best equipment.
I've never called the store yet and said,
we have equipment almost as good as.
Never, right?
Everybody always says they have the best equipment.
So that's all your customers ever hear.
So how do we differentiate ourselves?
We have to do it with what they see.
Here's an interesting fact, and I won't dive too much into it.
The average person speaks at about 145 words a minute.
My daughter, about 309.
145.
How many words per minute does the brain comprehend?
Anybody want to take a guess?
About 700.
That's why television is so much more expensive than radio, right?
Because visually, you see something, your brain takes in a picture,
you'll all know this one, a picture's worth...
There you go.
Now does it make sense? Right?
We see a picture, we take it in.
When somebody walks into your spa, what do they see?
They get a picture.
Their brain is thinking six times faster than you're speaking.
Do you understand now why people are making decisions so quickly?
If somebody gets in their car, drives to our place of business,
and they get out of their car, they wait their turn in line,
they finally get to the front counter,
you give them all the information and say,
thank you so much, I'm just looking.
Come on.
Did they get in their car, drive across town,
Park in the parking lot, get out of their car, wait in line to get prices.
No.
Something between when they walked in the store and decision-making time came turned them on.
That's so obvious, and yet we all sit here and we'll make excuses for it.
Well, some people are just price dollars.
If they walk out of your store, they did it because we did something wrong.
That's why they want that.
Accept it, go back to the working table, and let's figure it out.
So, finally, we're going to talk about orbs and sessions a little bit later on,
and we're going to look at EMP funds and how they can stimulate your business.
So, here are some of the modalities, and it's kind of interesting.
We talked earlier about Mystic Pan, and many of us might remember that.
When Mystic Pan came into the market, now they have different varieties.
That unit has evolved greatly, and they have a new unit here.
But I will tell you, there are so many people that were reluctant, that I knew personally,
to get into the settlements business.
Why?
For a couple of reasons.
Number one, it represented a new investment.
And most of us in this industry don't love spending money, especially, and we justify
it this way, particularly when it comes to tanning things.
Well, what I have works fine.
I mean, yeah, it looks like it was from 1964, but it tans great.
I mean, I give people tweezers when they go in it.
They're able to get the splinters out, and it works fine, right?
I mean, I've seen some equipment in stores so old, I'm not even sure who made it.
All the badging's worn off.
So, sometimes it's not what it costs us.
The smallest modalities should include services exempt from labor.
What's your number one line item on your P&O?
Staff? Labor?
I don't know how bad it is here in Canada.
We have a governor who thought it was going to be brilliant
to make the minimum wage at all fast food restaurants $20 an hour.
Well, what did that do to all retailers?
Now, if your employee can work at Taco Bell
taking ownership of the drive-thru for 20, and you want to pay them 18, yes, well, you're
going to be looking for new employees. And now it didn't begin a fight at 20, it began
a fight for employees at 22 to 23. Now, I realize things are different here on the Canadian
side, but then your managers, which were at 25 and 26, become 28 and 30. Your district
30 to 35 became 40 to 45.
It just snowballed.
And pretty soon, we got into a realm of unaffordability.
And so we've been fighting that battle ever since.
So when you include modalities that exclude labor,
sometimes we want to do things,
and the problem is that it takes somebody walking back,
showing somebody how to use it,
getting them prepared to use it.
It takes a lot of labor, right?
But if we could pick modalities that are T-Max compatible, that work within our system, that are easy to train somebody how to use.
So one of the first things we brought in in 2015 was the Zero Gravity Massage Chair, which is T-Max compatible.
Phenomenal experience. How many of you have had customers that say, you know what, I'm just going to stop handing.
I mean, I'm kind of plateaued.
I don't get results here anymore.
Anybody ever have that?
We have, right?
I don't get results anymore.
Well, newsflash, right?
You're white, right?
You're not going to become African American, right?
We can only make you so dark.
But I do have a solution for you.
We know that the better your oxygen and circulation and blood circulation,
the better tan you're going to get.
So what I want you to do today is I want you to use the wave, Herbaline Wave, which they
have next door.
It's going to be a gentle massage.
It's warm.
It's going to be your blood circulating, oxygen.
And then I want you to go down and you tell me if you don't see a difference.
Now some of it is the placebo effect, right?
I did, therefore I think I am.
So and they'll come out and they'll be like, oh my gosh, that made all the difference in
the world.
Well, we did two things now.
We got them to try a new service.
We got them to upgrade their membership because now that they did it once,
what do they want the next time they come in?
They want to do it again, right?
They want that same experience.
And let's face it, does anybody have the way?
If I get a choice to go next door and do something,
of all the modalities we have,
that thing is the most relaxing piece of equipment.
I think it's something about hearing the water in your ears.
It just puts me at the beach right away.
it. But it also works, guys. It's a great modality to add to your service. If you go
in the cocoon, what is the cocoon going to do? It's going to stimulate blood and oxygen.
It's going to give you a better tan. But there's more than just getting a better tan. You see
the purpose here? We're trying to get them into different modalities to complement what
they do. We've had so many people that have come in for other services that became light
light therapy customers just because of the wellness services they make.
The wellness industry is just growing exponentially.
I can't stress that enough.
I'm not saying get out of Tandy.
I'm saying complement it.
Complement it.
Take an opportunity to make a life-changing decision,
and instead of maybe it's one of these,
maybe it's instead of going on vacation,
you bought something that's going to allow you to go to Europe
instead of 20 miles away.
Think about things that are going to make you money, and they will.
The wellness industry is changing.
These are some of the wellness ads that we run.
We are very much beauty-driven.
Here's an interesting fact for you, again from the tanning industry.
Women may know this, men may not.
If you take any woman's magazine, Vogue, Cosmo, Glamour, Seventeen,
it doesn't matter what magazine it is,
and you put the most beautiful man on the front of that magazine,
what will happen? Sales will plummet 44%. Fact. Sales will plummet 44%. Who sells women?
Women sell women. Women sell women. A woman looks at the front cover of a magazine, she's
like, I love her hair. I've got to have those lips. She's got the most beautiful eyes.
Women sell women. If that's the case, why don't we take that philosophy and apply it
to our stores if we know that the person behind the counter sells the person in front of the
counter why don't we capitalize on that you see the value of having the sales staff trained to
look and feel the party that becomes critical we spend this is a couple pictures of our spas
um i mentioned back in 2015 we pivoted um we spend an enormous amount of money
on our stores but we are probably the first in the industry to say 2026 we thought we would do
it 2025 but i've got to be honest 2026 will be the first year that every single store in our brand
exceeds 1.3 million homes every single one how did we do it it's not one major thing guys it's
lots of little things. When you walk in, you feel like you're in a wellness spa. The people
behind the counter look like they work at a wellness spa. And guess what? We have equipment
that makes you feel like you're at a wellness spa. It's there for the taking, guys. I've
taken stores. The best story I have is Nicole Swoop from Oasis Canyon. You can look her
her up on the internet. She's out in Gillette, Wyoming. It's a coal mining town. And Nicole
hired me. Her mom and her came into town. And she said, you know, I don't know what
we're doing. I don't know that we're doing it right. She's doing $433,000 in Gillette,
Wyoming. Now, Gillette, Wyoming is a coal mining town. Her husband is a manager at the
plant. This is all, you can call her up and talk to her. And I said, Nicole, you've got
a million dollar operation. I've done all your numbers. Before somebody ever arrived,
we probably got a hundred hours worth of work in the analytics of their stores and she goes mike
that's impossible i said here's what i want to do so we rebranded her we changed her name i didn't
change her name we just changed the styling of it bought her brand a little bit more current
we changed her pricing her packages and two pieces of equipment at the end of that year
that was in january i think the end of january three years ago at the end of that year she
from 433 to 1.5 call her yourself she did so good in the following two years that she bought the
seven acres across from her store opened up her own shopping center where she is now the anchor
in that center and if that's not a success story i don't know what is not for me for her i can give
you ideas all day long but if you guys don't have the disciplines to actually it doesn't matter
Right? People often say, oh, man, thank God I came. No, thank God you have the ability to follow through. When you guys are here, guys, I am telling you what I did. What I did is I capitalized on what everybody else wasn't doing.
I would see vendors at trade shows talking to each other, walking around with nothing to do.
And I'm like, what the hell?
Like, you know, when I got into business, it was like we were in the CIA. Nobody could share ideas.
We'd have to kill you afterwards, right? Anybody remember those days?
Like, we don't want to share ideas.
So I just went to the vendors. And guess what?
They were happy to talk to me because they were talking to other vendors also.
And so I would just purge as much information as I could out of them.
And I'm going to find out from them what the big guys were doing, what the big guys gave up, what they were looking at doing.
I mean, you have in this room right now Randy and Marty.
I mean, Charles, these are guys that talk to thousands of locations.
If I had an opportunity, Randy, where's the market headed on Sunless?
What do you kind of see going on?
How many of us know Randy?
I mean, that guy's a plethora of information.
information. Charles represents both the European market and the U.S. market. He's got all the
analytics on him. Why wouldn't we find out, hey, what's really working? I mean, the one
thing I love about talking to Charles is he'll also tell you what's not working. And sometimes
that in itself can save us money, yeah? So take that opportunity, capitalize on it. I'm
not suggesting that everybody go out. In fact, the one thing I wouldn't suggest is we go
go back and we do this knee-jerk reaction.
Okay, we're gonna change some memberships,
we're gonna paint our stores this color,
everybody can start wearing scrubs,
we're gonna tell them to fire if you don't wear them,
air if you don't, and we're gonna go out, right?
Yeah, 100%.
And by the way, your nails have to be a certain color.
We're just gonna add to it.
That's crazy, guys.
Plan it out, think it through,
come up with an executable strategy
that your employees will embrace.
grace. And they will love it. They will feel better about it. My time is up, but I will
tell you this, that dreaming of a change doesn't make us a visionary. Sometimes we come away
and people say, well, you're the owner, you can do whatever you want. You're the visionary.
And we dream about it all day long. We see what others are doing. We hear what others
are doing. We talk to other people and hear about the things we should be doing or the
the equipment that they're buying, and we say, oh, it's just three months a day, I don't
think it's happening.
Make it happen.
You know, we know for a fact that about the first $350,000, $400,000 is really a marginal
profit margin.
But once you get over $400,000, you ready?
Most of the people I've done, when you cross over $400,000, we change to a 76% profit margin.
So why aren't we going after the 70%?
I talk to people all the time.
They're like, oh, I'm just, you know, it's just uncomfortable doing what I do.
Change is hard.
You know, plus it's hard to keep staff.
Why is it hard to keep staff?
Because we refuse to change.
They want new things.
They want new products, new modalities.
They want new life products.
on it. Do that
and both of you will prosper, I promise
you. I'm going to be here
for the whole day, regardless. You guys are more
than welcome to come up and talk to me.
I look forward to sharing the numbers
because if you really want to find out what we're
looking at to make it happen, and
the proof behind what we're doing,
that's at 2.30.
So thank you so much for your attention.
Thank you.
Was that great, guys?
Thank you guys for coming back again this afternoon to talk about his numbers.
Everybody, I think Elaine deserves a round of applause.
Next up, I've got a really great friend of mine, Brandon's here.
Brandon is from, formerly known as Sumlin's Inc., is now Inove.
Inove is redefining the industry by seamlessly blending beauty, science, and technology,
setting the standards in high-end skincare, beauty tech, and full-body solutions.
Today Brendan is going to share some of Novi's new technology and new properties and new technology with us.
So a big round of applause for Brendan.